Hey, what's going on? It's bill burns
time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast. And I am just checking in on you.
That's it is, you might notice my
voice is a couple octaves lower. Uh,
I've been doing shows all this week,
um, and I was sick like a month ago,
so I don't know that it's
fucking recovered, but uh,
I don't have my usual, uh,
you know, mid range voice,
but this, I promise you
this is me anyways. Um,
I'm up here in San Francisco with the
North's theater with a Nate Kraig.
We've been having a great time all
week. Um, last night, you know,
it's one of those nights,
just had a great show.
It was like I didn't want to fucking go
home, so we ended up going over to a,
was just walking around and
ended up just at the Fillmore.
So we walk over, it goes, go fucking go
over there, have a drink or something.
Right, because Billy's off
the wagon again. Right.
I guess when I get home I'll get back
on the fucking wagon. I'm the worst.
I'm either on or I'm off and I'm off.
Yabber anyway,
sorry. Um, by the way,
if you want o see arguably some of
the funniest shit on the Internet.
Nay.
Craig told me about Kyle done against a
Instagram page and I guess Joe Rogan and
Tom Segora. Those guys
have all hyped it. I don't,
I've been completely out of the loop.
That guy's one of the
funniest fucking comedians.
I've always been a huge
fan of his stuff and um,
and I thought it was so fucking
original, but I, his Instagram page,
I can't even describe how,
how fucking hilarious I was like every
morning for like the last three days I've
been watching all of his
videos for like an hour,
just laying in bed crying, laughing. Um,
his Instagram is at Kyle done
again. K, y. L. E d, u. N, n.
I. G. A. N. A hope I spelled that
right. And the num number one,
and he does like that face swap thing
and he does this fucking ridiculous
impression of everybody.
Bill Maher,
Donald Trump, uh, Caitlin Jenner,
all the Kardashians.
Um,
just everything that he does,
his fuck is bill Maher's ridiculous.
And then he got like all these
different Trump's, he's got tiny Trump,
trans Trump, just Trump in general. Um,
it's fucking unbelievable. Um,
so check that out. So anyways,
um, we ended up walking over to the, uh,
we ended up over at the Fillmore.
Should we go to walk in, you know,
and there's a band playing. So of
course the secure, is that right?
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
We're like, yeah, hey, we're just going
in there to get a drink. And the guy goes,
you can't, there's a show going on.
This is a concert venue. You know,
I taped a specialty. I was kind of
funny. I said, yeah, I know. I go,
I've performed here. He goes, Oh, you've
performed here. I've never done this.
I just said, yeah, I'm a comedian. I
just want to go on and have a drink.
And then fortunately, he recognized me
and I was able to pull that fucking card.
I never pull a car.
It was pretty cool.
So then I went upstairs and I just
hear this fucking woman's voice.
He's just incredible playing the guitar.
Incredible.
And I poked my head in to see,
and you know,
there's this big tour bus to this shit,
but there wasn't a band on stage.
It was just,
you know,
you know when the one person is up there
and they're playing to a loop and then
they loop it with something else, the
Pr, you know, she was doing that shit.
I was like, ah man, I miss seeing bands.
I get it all the fucking crowd stole
the music and the fucking labels do the
cross the board
fucking deals with or even take a PC,
a emerge, you know, the greedy cunts.
So I get it. So it was just like, yeah.
So it was kind of bummed out even
though her voice was fucking incredible.
It's just like,
I like watching a live band cause I like
when I want to bands like improvising
and shit.
I always love watching like Stevie Ray
Vaughan cause she'd see Tommy and uh,
Chris Layton, well never stopped looking
at them cause they're like, all right,
what's he doing?
Is he going to go around again or is
he going to fucking go into the verse?
You know, when, you know,
when it start to come to the point
where he would come out of the Solos,
are you going to keep solo
and what is he going to do?
And when you just see that and then
you see Stevie just give them like this
fucking little nod as he's
wailing on the guitar.
And then they just seamlessly
in that moment know that,
that go into this next session.
That's what I fucking love. Um,
so it's just one person updates, you
know, but you're here in a band. I get,
you know, I'm a fucking old guy, Amar.
Where's the rest of the people? Right.
So I walked into the other Roman, I
was sitting there with Nate, you know,
and I'm just listening to this woman
singing and I'm like, oh my God,
she's fucking unreal.
I'm here a little Amy Winehouse
suggest she's incredible and uh,
had a drink or something. And then
I go, man, that's, I swear to God,
that sounds like a band.
And then I walked back out there and now
there's a whole band on stage and I'm
like,
where the fuck did that woman go?
Was she opening like what the fuck
was going on? Long Story Short,
I find out it wasn't a woman who was a
guy and his name is Alan Stone and that
was one of the fucking best
voices I've ever heard in my life.
Incredible Guitar player. When
you see the name of the band, um,
it was funny, we went
in there, it was like a,
like all these hardcore fans of this band
is called Andrew Andrew McMahon in the
wilderness.
Now granted this isn't like my necessarily
my style of music that I would listen
to, but like how well
these people sang was just,
it was fucking incredible.
The Piano player was cracking me up
because he was dressed like Kenny Loggins
and like the early eighties,
and like if you looked at the guy,
like that guy is going to
have a major cocaine problem.
He had like the Kenny Loggins beard and
then he had the sweater tied around his
neck.
Um,
like when I came up in the 80s,
anytime they were going to have like an
asshole in a fucking coming of age movie
in the 80s, they always had the
sweater tied around him, you know,
if the fucking frat boy or whatever.
But anyways,
but it was a completely different vibe
and afterwards,
all these nerdy Chicsville going
out and talking and look at my face.
Can you tell I was crying. They
were crying. There was definitely,
I don't know what was going on,
but it was definitely sort of
the crowd was those, you know,
the kids who can't throw a ball,
you know,
and aren't good at fighting. It
was that group of people. Um,
and they were fucking ended this band
and this band was fucking amazing.
Fucking amazing.
But what was hilarious was the bartenders
were all bored as shit because none of
them were drinking.
The Fillmore has this really long bar
that goes all the way down the left side.
And these fucking bartenders would
just leaning with their backs against,
you know,
where the cash registers.
That shit where with this looks
on their faces. It's like,
how the fuck did I get this shift?
I'm not going to make any fucking
money tonight. But anyways, um,
if he get a chance to see them live or
ever get a chance to see that Alan Stone,
I just was looking him up and he was
singing with the Daryl Hall and stuff.
Evidently the guys is like fucking
legendary. And I'm going like,
who's this chick? Why?
Where's the rest of the band?
And I just walk in the other room.
So fucking stupid.
But I'm glad that I was able to,
uh,
cause I was talking with people afterwards
when they will leave and I go, well,
where was that woman? And they will
laugh and go, and that wasn't a woman.
That was a guy. I go, that
was a guy, Dave Allen's down.
God. Um, anyways, uh,
so I went up when I saw that there
was a whole bad, like I've, you know,
I've only been to the Fillmore
a couple times and um,
when you're upstairs you got,
you know,
unless you have like the two old guys in
the muppet show seats in those things,
it's very hard to see the band.
But then there's this one area
where it's straight on, so upstairs,
so I walk and there was this
woman's security sitting down. I go,
is it okay to walk over there? And
she goes, did that section is private.
And I wanted to be like,
I only asked you once,
you fucking cunt. I don't know if
she was yelling over the music,
but it was just like,
what the f I felt like it was on like
a seven year relationship with her and
whatever the fuck it is that I,
I do that bugs or I just did it.
That section has private,
uh,
you know what I thought about,
you know,
who's that guy used to climb
in to the ring? Like a spider.
The Guy who kicked the guy in, broke
his leg in half. Um, Anderson Silva.
I remember that front kick he would
do and you just didn't see it coming,
you know, that went into my head
when she leaned forward. Private.
Just give the old right there Fred.
You know,
and I would do that as an empowering
move to a woman, you know,
treating her as an equal like, well
that's what you would do to a guy. Right.
How come women don't want that part
of equal rights? It's all right.
You want to make what we
make then uh, you, you know,
you gotta take a Mitt to the
face every once in a while.
By the way, I've been such an
asshole on stage this week.
I've been having such a good time. I
said someone was ridiculous shit. Um,
I dunno that I've said, I don't
think ever, I've just been like,
it's a total reaction to like, what
the f all this fucking crap out there.
You know, I did this interview
recently and I was talking to this guy,
I'll probably get in
trouble for the show camera.
What the fuck are you talking
about? But the guy goes, yeah,
but you can't say they can't see. It's
like, what's food? Fuck yes I can.
You can't say why. Why did people all
of a sudden won't know their jokes?
And then then there'll be,
yeah, what's going on? What
the fuck is going to happen?
Um,
so anyways,
I been up here all this week and um,
I got this thing in my writer, but if
I spend more than one night someplace,
they'll bring in some old drum kit or
whatever and I just play on it during the
day. So, uh, I'm up here and I dunno, the,
one of the guys who,
uh,
works at the theater is a drummer and
they get me this sick fucking Dwu kit.
That sounds amazing.
I brought my double pedal up and I brought
my fucking that while that music that
I wrote out on that a Metallica song just
been having like the best fucking time
ever, although I'm missing my
wife and my kid big time. But, um,
this really is a, an amazing city. And I
had a friend of mine come out last night,
uh, who I hadn't seen in awhile and
I kind of learned some shit though.
I was glad that we hung out there rather
than over at the punchline because I
really like how my brain works as far as
when I get depressed is when I tried to
go into the past.
You know,
like if you go into a place that
you haven't been in a long time,
like you're all excited and then you
walk in there and like, nobody that,
you know, you don't know anybody
anymore and you're like that, ah, fuck,
I'm old. The time came and it
went, why did I enjoy it more?
Ooh, you know, so I was glad
I met her over there. But uh,
you know,
she just was one of the people,
I don't know if this should have been
a person like her and every comedy town
because she fucking her tastes and
comedians and how much she gave,
there's still gives a shit about comedy.
He was,
I think one of the major reasons why the
standup scene here has always been so
frigging strong. So anyways, let's, uh,
let's plow ahead. I went to the
giants game yesterday. The, uh,
the baseball giants,
uh,
they had a day game fucking started
at like one o'clock and I'm,
Nate was giving me all this shit
because I was keeping score.
When I go to baseball games, I like
to keep score because if, if I don't,
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
You know, there's literally 18 people,
you know, you don't know who's
given up hits in the eye.
You literally make a pitching
change and you don't even hear it.
Cause there's so much fucking
shit going on, you know?
And at the giants they have this woman
doing the fucking announcements and like
they have voice just, it just doesn't
carry, like, I don't know what it is.
Like you need the base to cut through.
She's [inaudible].
Yeah. I'm like, what the fuck did she say?
Then I'd have to look at the number and
then I got to look it up on my phone.
It's like you just announced it over a PA
system. How the fuck did I not hear it?
Um, I played drums. Maybe my
ears are fucked up. I don't
know. I don't know what.
But um,
I got a $12 cores at that
fucking ballpark and a boy.
What's funny is when
you get the scorecard,
the scorecard is a dollar and then
they make you pay for the pencil.
Now the pencils, a buck, it's like
the cheapest thing in the park.
And got a bag of peanuts and had an ice
cold beer. I sat there keeping scores,
fucking gray. Only thing I was missing
was a cigar would have been perfect.
And I'm this fucking Guy Suarez.
Got Sheldon the first dating
and then he settled down.
But the giants were never able to catch
up. It was, you know, it's a good game.
It's definitely good game. Beautiful
Ballpark. The reds got some guy on their,
on their, uh, their team,
little fella and he goes by scooter.
So like I'd be like, you know,
at some point you got to call me by my
name, but he still goes by scooter. Right.
So we're sitting there going like,
Nate's going,
how tall do you think that guy is?
I'm like,
that guy might be a couple
inches shorter than me.
And then he steps up to the plate and
just fucking crushes one crushes one all
the way out to the fucking, I call it
the ocean. Mccovey is bay cove. Sorry,
cubbies cove, whatever the fuck it is. Um,
I think that's why he
still goes by scooter,
cause that's got to really fuck with
the other PR, the pictures, you know,
confidence.
I mean you just step up to the plate
and name's Mike and he'd go yard.
He's not going to give a fuck with some
guy named scooter hits the ball into the
fuck. You know your best pitch into the
fucking ocean. That's good. You know,
you gotta be, you gotta take a
lap around the mouth going like,
is this the end of my career?
Some fucking make a wish kid just came
up and just fucking crushed into the
ocean. Um, anyways,
how about those Boston Celtics.
Okay.
Once again, I'm working every
fucking night. This week,
I've missed every second of
the last series in this series.
I just keep watching the
highlights and um, and defense,
the Cavaliers, uhh, I guess they have
the worst team defense in the league.
Um, but you know, Brad Stevens I guess
is out coaching them and all that stuff.
But, uh, I gotta be honest with Ya,
I really won't feel comfortable that
we're going to beat the cavs until we win
the fourth game.
Cause if the Cavs went tonight,
I'm assuming the plane tonight,
then all of a sudden it's two one and
he just gets scary again. Like, Oh fuck,
here comes to Lebron.
Hit comes Lebron. I mean,
you're talking about a guy who
has led his teams to the finals,
how many years in a row? And I don't give
a fuck that he was on a pile on team.
Coby was on a pile on team his entire
fucking career and he didn't go to the
finals fucking, you know, seven
years in a row, whatever the hell,
okay,
Lebron is working on right now.
So, uh, we shall see this is all,
you know,
it's all gravy,
but they just keep winning
in the fucking rocket speed.
The goddamn warriors last night,
I guess, which is incredible.
Um, you just can't root for the warriors.
Once Duran went to the warriors,
you just can't fucking real. It's the
stupidest, it's so fucking stupid.
It makes the Miami Heat not
look like a pile on team again.
Maybe he was a pilot thing, but I'm
just saying, you know what I mean?
Was the NBA was self,
I know I've said this a thousand night,
but the NBA was so fucking great that
warriors thunder series with thunder went
up three games to one and then they
fucked it up because they were too young.
They didn't know how to win.
And the warriors showed the
championship heart that they had.
And then that was the story the next year.
Okay.
Was where the thunder going
to fucking get over the hump,
where they going to dig down deep and,
and,
and slay the fucking dragon.
And what happens?
Okay,
Luke Skywalker goes, you
know what? You are my father.
I'll fucking join the dark side in fucking
Kevin Durant just goes over there and
the second he went over there,
everybody who watches Nba hoop goes, oh,
the warriors are going to win the
championship. And then they did.
It was fucking boring as shit.
Yeah.
Um,
the only thing I like about it
okay,
is that Darren didn't go to the
Lakers and I have to watch them,
you know, once again, free agent their
way to yet another fucking championship,
which admittedly is a Celtics fan.
We did in 2008 but the fucking,
you know,
I've watched the Lakers get
five championships in the
last like 20 years doing
shit like that and it's just,
you know, gets fucking tired
after a while, you know.
Um, especially because, you
know, according to them,
their one championship
behind us, which, you know,
we all know through Bill
Simmons Book Than Not that too.
And we also know there was a mobbed up
fucking ref that fixed that Sacramento
serious, so they get fucking
two banners, you know. But, uh,
what I do like about it is that's
very la to pad your resume, you know,
to make Instagram videos and then
call yourself a director. Um, anyways,
so I am a,
I dunno,
we'll see what happens. I wish I could
just watch one of these fucking games.
If we get by the Cavaliers
and the warriors, you know,
of course they're going to
go to the fucking finals.
How are they not going to
win a championship when
you have like every fucking
good guy in the league is
on your God damn team. Um,
I mean,
I dunno,
the Celtics actually could win one or
two games against the fucking warriors.
I mean, I'm not looking ahead here.
I mean, that'd be what I'm real.
And then we got Kyrie Irving
free agent guy right there, Bill.
You fucking hypocrite. Um,
yeah, but we're upstart too.
Those are all fucking, I'll
fucking, everybody adds one
free fucking agent, right?
That's all I'm saying. It was just, it
was just bad. I just don't understand why,
you know,
I fucking hate the legs,
but I don't understand why that one
guy couldn't go to the fucking Lakers,
but Kevin Durant could go to
the fucking gold state wage.
Did you killed all?
He killed the whole fucking story.
Yeah.
It'd be like if when the Celtics beat
the Lakers and 84th magic said fuck it,
they just joined the Celtics.
I Dunno, whatever. I'm an old guy.
The Celtic signed free agents too.
But let me, I would, I would think
if we went to make a move like that,
um, someone was actually
saying that, you know,
Duran or somebody is up for free
agency and he might go to the Celtics.
And I was thinking,
I don't fucking want that guy.
I don't know to become
part of the problem.
Yeah.
He's just going to bounce
around the league. No
picking up rings. I, you know, and this
is from a guy who barely watches the NBA.
Why am I the subset?
I'll tell you why.
I'm the subset now that he asked
the question for, for you guys.
Now I'm going to answer it. I just
remember when I was at, when you were,
when you were a fucking kid and you had
outdoor recess and you would choose an
up teams, even as little kids, if it
got too lopsided, you'd be like, oh,
wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait, wait. Even it out.
Because even then you knew like, where
would the satisfaction be in winning?
Kids know, kids know not to do what
the fuck they're doing. But I mean,
that is the way it's done now.
I mean, free agency, again,
I should just accept the fact,
okay, here's, okay, here's the deal.
I accept the fact that there's free age.
It's okay. And I admit that the Celtics,
you know, we bought a
championship in 2008. Okay,
okay.
And uh, you know, and we also had a Kyrie
Irving this year, but you know, maybe,
you know, fuming Lebron could get
along a little better. I mean, I don't,
I don't fucking know, but there has
to, should that should be aligned.
You know, that that Miami, he
thinks shouldn't have fucking
happen. The, the, the uh,
what's his face trade.
Okay.
Kevin Garnett with Kevin Mchale and the
front office gives us old team Kevin
Garnett for nothing that
should have been blocked,
would pog is saw with Jerry West
and the front office went to Lakers.
That should have been blocked. Just shit
like that. That's all I'm saying. Sick.
So I took a little burden on there,
you know, maybe, I don't know. Fuck it.
Who gives a fuck?
Um,
okay.
So anyways, uh, what do I got here?
I got two more God damn show.
You have no rights.
I have no reeds here on Thursday.
Uh,
and I'm trying desperately not to do my
impression of countdown against Donald
Trump or fucking bill Maher to his bill
Maher is so fucking ridiculously on.
Have you ever seen the
one he does? Um, where he,
she has like Bill Maher
reading to children.
He's stringing reading like nursery
rhymes. He's like, hey dude, it'll do,
it'll do cat and the fiddle. Okay.
The cow jumped over the moon.
Really over the moon.
This story is bullshit.
He just like makes the kids cry.
I know I'm doing a shit version of you
got it here the guy stop listening my
podcast and go, here's some real
comedy at, at Kyle done to get one.
The guy's a fucking genius.
I don't get how that guy is not on
Saturday night life. I just don't.
Okay.
You know, I, I bet you know why. Cause
they wouldn't do the Caitlyn Jenner Shit.
I Dunno what happened. They, they're
all fucking political over there now.
That used to be rebellious,
you know,
you've got to see is Caitlyn
Jenner. Shit baby Trump. All right,
I'm done hyping it. I don't want to
fucking overhype it. I can't over hype,
but it's fucking hilarious.
Alright, plowing ahead here. Um,
so I got what's tonight?
Thursday,
I've got two more shows up here
and then that's the end. Um,
I'm going to be just doing a bunch
of sets around La, get ready for 'em
my, my big shows there in, uh,
in Europe and then my big birthday
turning 50 next fucking month.
You know, I don't feel any different.
My shoulders fucking great.
Here's the deal. Every year on
my birthday I got to do like uh,
the amount of pushups for whatever year
I am and I haven't done them the last
couple of years cause my
shoulders but fucked up.
So I think the last time I did was I
turned 47 so I'm up to doing sets of 35 so
I'm right on right on pace here and
maybe then turning 50 won't be as
devastating.
But I did 50 shops.
Does that make me a mortal?
Um,
anyways,
you know what I think we'll have,
this podcast is going
to be a little short.
I mean I don't think I have
anything else to talk about man.
How the fuck am I going to fill up
these I feel, I don't even know why.
I mean self employed.
Why do, why do I feel,
what am I going to fire myself if
I know through a full half hour?
Is that what it's going to be at?
You know the red sox are
actually playing the Oakland A's.
I was thinking of going over
there like an asshole. You know,
what I did here in the San Francisco
was joking. I did the impossible.
I actually got a fucking sunburn in
San Francisco like the sun was out,
but I was just like, it's San Francisco.
It's always cold and shitty here. Um,
they just have miserable fucking
weather. Um, that, you know,
they have the great white shark fucking
weather, right? The water's freezing.
No one ever made it off the
rock man. Right. It's just
always like that. In fact,
I used to always come here and every
time I would come here I'd get sick. Um,
I dunno why it was like
the flight from new,
I was living in New York and every time
I'd come out to do the punchline I would
get sick because a I way I
wasn't taking care of myself.
Then I had that extra long flight and
then I would step off into this just cold,
damp, fucking awful weather. And like
three times in a row when I came here,
I got sick. And, um,
Molly at the punchline.
I remember the last time I came out there,
she sent me like fucking
sent me all these vitamins,
c packages,
just fucking drinking a zillion
of them before he got out there.
So I would get sick. I started to
think I was allergic to this down.
So when I looked,
you know,
I looked up the fucking weather coming up
here as I was waiting for it to pop up.
I just said cold and shitty.
And I looked at it and it was every day
there was clouds with a little bit of
Sun and then rain and I don't know
what happened. Something changed.
So yesterday we, uh, we walked
over to the ballpark and I'm,
I'm like, God, this is going to
burn off. This is going to burn off.
I bought a couple of
really good seats and uh,
I was just sitting in the sun the whole
fucking time wearing a north face jacket,
sweating my ass off. But I was like, oh,
I can't take this off cause
I got on shorts sleeves
underneath that I'm going to
fucking burn up.
So I sat there and a winter coat in
like 75 degree weather keeping score.
I looked like a fucking,
you know,
the only thing I was missing was those
giant headphones with like the am radio
antenna sticking out of it. Um, those
are the fucking lunatics though.
Like I wasn't that bad of a nerd.
You know,
those guys who actually listened to the
ball game while they're watching it and
they're keeping score. Um, but I'll tell
you, they know everything that's going on.
They know when they
make a pitching change,
when there's a pinch hitter and all of
that shit, like trying to keep score,
like when you're out in the outfield.
The only way I was able to do
it cause I was, uh, and um,
right behind home plate.
So when somebody came up on on deck,
I would just check the number to make
sure they didn't switch somebody out. Um,
and that's my exciting
story about keeping score.
All right, I'm finished. I'm
starving. I'm going to go.
I've been eating good even
though I've been drinking again,
which I don't fucking like,
but it just get,
I get fucking bored when I'm out here.
What am I going to do
you want to fuck me up?
Was I brought my resent a stone up here.
I brought the little external fucking
dis thing that you stick it in.
I plug it in and I left
the fucking disc at home.
So now what am I supposed to do? Am I
supposed to get some folk a coloring book?
My shows are at seven every night.
I'm done by nine. I'm all wound up.
You know, I've seen more goddamn
couples arguing and public up here.
The city is more expensive I guess than
even New York City for rent or to buy
something and you can really
see the stress on the people
just screaming at each
other.
So that three times yesterday.
Okay.
And I'll tell you the
woman was winning all three
and each one of the relationships, I was
like, she's a lot smarter than that guy.
Why is she with this person?
Because like the guy was like
trying to come back. You know
the rocky Balboa.
What about you? Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
And the woman would just rattling off
all the things that this guy was fucking
up a credit. I was just
walking by, you know,
I experienced a relationship for five
seconds and my immediate thought other
than these two people need the
break up was uh, you know, I, she,
she's got you there buddy.
She's making a lot of good points.
Yeah.
And I have been joking
about this onstage to,
San Francisco has the most homeless
homeless people I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah.
It's almost like they're not real. They're
so fucking homeless. There's skid row.
It's just fucking,
it's unbelievable.
We walked by this woman,
she was literally passed out in her
hand was on the ground and there was an
empty bottle of booze that like,
so artistically had just rolled like,
like two and a half
inches away from her hand.
Yeah.
It looked like you were
on you. Yeah. Like you,
one of the set of a movie about
homeless people like that,
that's just such a perfect shot.
You know about alcoholism and
addiction and all of that type of shit.
But it's like real. Yeah. We will
like walking off from the park,
trying to avoid the hills,
you know, as much as we could.
And we just got into this.
It was like, you know,
everybody's got their skid row.
They have a neighborhood,
just a fucking name.
You just walking through,
you know,
I saw this fucking guy,
he's in a wheelchair when these guys
in a wheelchair, but his legs work,
whatever the fuck that
deal is, you know? And uh,
he just had like his shirt pulled
up over his face and then his hands,
like covering his face, like he was
the saddest person on the planet.
You know,
I was walking around with the Fillmore
and this is blind guy, just asking people,
somebody can help them cross the street.
Yeah.
So I was like, all right,
I'm going that way, you know?
And then he grabs my arm and
then I immediately put my
hand on my wallet because
it's like, all right, I know
I'm a gullible white guy,
but I'm not that fucking dumb.
All right.
So I go to step off the curb and he
goes, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
And I was like, Oh yeah, you're
right. It's fucking green.
And then I'm looking at him like,
I start laughing like,
how the fuck did you know
that that light was great?
Okay.
And he started laughing.
I forget what the fuck.
I guess it makes a noise or some shit like
that, but I almost walked a blind guy.
He goes,
you got to watch out for the buses
that was walked a blind guy, right
it right into the fucking bus. Um,
so I'm a fucking liberal SAP,
you know, this woman says to me,
can you give me blah, blah, blah?
And she look all sad and some subway,
she fucking asked me. I was like, ah,
give us some money. And I said, Nate,
you think she's drinking?
And he goes, yeah. And I was,
I was like, all right, forget it.
I won't fucking, and he goes, look,
if you want to go buy her a sandwich,
I'll fucking do that. And I was like,
all right, all right. You know? Well,
maybe she needs some fucking boots.
I got a phone call. Oh, look who it is.
Look cool. What is an old friend
of the podcast? Joe To Rosa. Joe,
I got you on speaker
recording right now.
I'm recording. Wrapping up, Joe. Joe,
remember we used to do on informed,
remember we used to wrap.
Well that's good.
When are we ever going to do
another episode of anything?
Uh, no. I gotta tell Ya.
Fans across the country have
asked the same question and
was that plural or was it just, was that
one fan or did you actually save fans?
There was a fan,
at least one guy in every
city asked the same question
after, after I opened. People ask
me all the time, nope, no bullshit.
And after I opened for you and uh,
what was the ladder,
but the chip load people came up to me
after the show outside and we're like,
what are you doing on it for us? I
was like, dude, I want to, I, I just,
uh, it's hard, you know,
you know, it's fucking hilarious
about all of this shit. Joe,
if I jumped in my car,
how quickly would I get to your apartment
with no traffic?
W with no traffic.
I got a whole set up over here.
Let's just do one
Joe.
I gotta be honest with you.
I have the weirdest relationship with
you out of all of my friends because we
never had a falling out.
But how little we see each other
and how close we live together.
It's like we had a out, I don't know
what happened, what happened to us, Joe.
So we travel outside of what happened.
Nothing happened.
We transcended into family territory.
I consider you family at this
point and you know, you've seen,
you don't see your family that much.
Yeah,
I mean, honestly, dude, I
look at you as her family. I'm
like, yeah, you know, we're,
we're good.
We're good.
Family Bag D. Um, all right,
well I think there's a
reason why you called.
So I guess week we got to do something.
We got it.
We got to at least I got to have
you on the podcast is a guest.
Is there anything you'd
want to promote Joe?
Uh, Bill, I have a podcast on my
own and I will see you with hell.
Oh, it's okay. It's about
that. It's like Jesus, Joe.
He said it's about horror movies.
Sorry, I talked over here.
She could check that out and I'm,
I'm not the old San Jose.
A rooster teeth feathers at the end of
the month here the last week of May.
Ah, you're going to shake your ass
up there in northern California.
Yup.
Yeah.
Shaking my fucking tail feathers.
Making you money. All right. Let me end
this fucking podcast. Hang on one second.
All right, and I'll, I'll talk to
you about what are the bullshit.
You want to talk about it, right? Hey, by
the way, I'd be like, no, no, wait, no.
Stay on for say, Hey, have
you gone to Kyle? Donna,
have you been on cal done
against Instagram page.
Kyle Dunnigan snow,
dude, it's, it's the funniest
shit. You have to go on it.
It's some of the funniest shit
I've seen on the fucking Internet.
I'm not threatening your job. I'm just
saying you got to do it. All right.
Let me wrap up this podcast. Don't
fucking hang up cause you won't pick up.
You know, you never pick up unless
it's a broad there. Um, all right.
That's, that's the Thursday afternoon
podcast. I got to talk to my uh,
Mike fucking step brother Joe to
Rosa here. Enjoy the music and uh,
the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, greatest
hits that will follow here.
All right, I'll check in
on you on Monday. You cuts.
Yeah,
I'm out of my pocket.
I do like when I'm out here,
I literally had to a rule about
just relaxing when I drive.
And one thing that it helps,
it's very therapeutic for me is letting
people go if you're really liking it.
I get so frustrated with the quality of
the driving out here at the inability to
fucking make turns at a decent speed and
we'll do it when they go buy shit out
here. The second they pass it, it's
it. They don't even remember it.
They have no fears, no fucking
clue. As for what's behind you.
Like you know what they do here,
I'd hear that fucking drives me.
Now you'll be sitting behind some
guy to a red light, you know,
in Europe on his bumper,
you know,
like you're supposed to be not in
crazy and it's the light turns green.
He then puts his left fucking direct,
no lines, absolute enraging and it's
self centered and yeah, it's, it's, it's,
I'm with you.
It's wrong that I fantasize about pushing
him into traffic and know it's wrong
that you don't have the moral
courage to do it. That's totally,
I think that's totally right.
And whenever you hear about someone
getting shot and killed for road rage,
everyone folks goes, oh my God,
that maniac that shot, that person.
And I honest to God,
the first thing I think is I'm glad like,
and until I find out the guy with the
gun was the Dick who fucked up for it.
I love that you have to find out that
the guy with the gun was a dick. I know.
To find that out.
The guy with the gun overreacted a little
something about,
because people are so self centered
in narcissistic when they drive it,
it's a reflection of who they really are.
So that's why we take it so fucking
personally may like let you let people go.
If the guy, if the guy doesn't wave thank
you to me, he don't do that. I've heard,
and Wilson,
they don't do that out here.
And I go from like being this
fucking mother Theresa Person.
I turned it to the devil. It
starts, I try to stay calm as such,
with a couple of release and my car.
I just got really, really, really,
you're not going to fuck these fucking
people out of here. I don't know.
What the fuck are you to
move down here for it?
I ended up turning into that
just because some douche.
Do you see the look on their face? They're
like, please, please, please let me go.
And you go to let them go
and you think like, Oh hey,
thumbs up something. Nothing.
They immediately, I just
back into their own. Uh,
I don't know.
I find sometimes I wave at people out
here and they look at me like weird. Like,
what do you know me?
Like, I maybe, you know,
I did move 2,500 miles away
from where I learned, you know,
societal rules. So maybe, uh, but you
know, you just think if, you know,
if you're waving to another white guy, I
mean we're pretty fucking generic. Yeah.
You know,
there's not a lot of
depth of the culture here because
that there's no gang signs.
I can see black guys get a little freak
out watching which your fingers a turn.
Well,
plus east coast though is,
it's so aggressive and I
hate to do like an la thing,
but out here maybe that courtesy
like in Boston or New York,
if someone lets you cut it and it's like,
hey mother Fucker,
I did you occur to seeing like,
Hey,
thank you for the car to say you're a
good shit though. Welcome, you're welcome.
But here it's like,
well that was just expected because they
might do that for each other more out
here. It's not a big deal.
That's the only I can think of.
I was in the Pennsylvania turnpike one
time driving to a Gig and I know I'm
popping all over every,
I'm very self conscious talking.
No, you're doing, you're doing
much better. But I don't have,
I don't have anybody to
help us out with this.
Okay.
I was driving to a Gig and the guy cut
into my lane and I was doing about 70 it
was raining and he had a trailer
that's not normal.
And I'm like,
yeah, it was a real drive
to my Mustang. Real punk,
your shit fucking hydroplaning Karger
call and I'm driving and this guy's coming
into my lane and I immediately, your
mind when you think you're going to die,
it goes very quickly. And I'm like,
okay, you got to slam on the brakes.
You're going to have an accident.
Hit the wall. Like it tried to, it's
that's smart. Yeah. Slow, slow
yourself down. Sideswiped the wall.
So I jam on the brake,
I hit the horn and he veers out
and we don't have the accident.
So then I'm not afraid. I'm in a
rage at this fucking guy. Right.
And I pull up next to him and it's a,
it's a like a,
you don't have a fat
black dude like it all.
Family Mopey guy and I'm ready to really,
you know Cleveland from
family guy actually. Yes.
William Stephenson fellows or the commerce
and now he looks at me and he
gives me the like, oops, I fucked
dup. Wave Up. Sorry.
And it gives me that and every bit of
anger drink cause he just owned up to it.
I'm sorry and sorry. Yet
I wave back. No problem.
That was it in a second my rage.
It was gone. You know what's funny?
I sometimes when somebody acts on the
rage, even though I know it's wrong,
I sort of lived through the,
the fucking ecstasy
that that must be like,
do you remember when Russell Crowe
through the phone? That's the guy.
I just can't imagine.
Like when you're in a hotel and you're
not getting the customer service you want
on whatever it is that the fact that
you actually take the machine that they
won't help you with and
fucking hurt somebody, the
person who is not helping you,
you fucking hurt him with it. Completely
wrong thing to do. But I can't imagine.
I always was wondering why. Cause
he's letting that phone go. Just Ah,
just fucking all that rage going on him.
I think it was, it was good for him.
It was bad for the guy behind the,
uh,
behind the counter behind
the counter was born
well learned a lesson that day.
Russell Crowe learn not to do it.
The other guy probably learned better
fucking customer service next time because
I remember when that happened,
I was in the Greenwich Hotel and uh,
which Dinair owns and I remember like,
Oh my God, that's a really
nice place. It's a beautiful,
like he would stay at a die
for on a stupid comment.
But I remember thinking this satisfaction,
it must've felt when the phone
hit the guy, like how good.
That must've felt a throw that phone
with that motherfucker. And again,
he got in big trouble for
that. But yeah, that was the,
do you know how mad you are?
You're,
you're pulling the wires out of the wall
and that voice is still not going. Okay,
what are you doing? What are you
doing? And then you wrap it up,
you leave your hotel, you walking
down the hall, he leave Your Room,
you get into the fucking elevator
and your brain's still going. Yeah.
Throw it at him. Yeah, throw it
out. What happened? Well, I mean he,
he went downstairs to the front.
I mean I don't,
I was just going to pick the phone up
off the desk and just do it on him. Oh,
I thought he was upstairs in his room.
Maybe he was, but I thought the, I didn't,
I didn't, I thought he just picked
the phone up and threw it at the guy.
That makes way more satisfying.
I find
out that he actually wrapped the cord
and took the phone from downstairs.
That makes me love him more. I was,
I loved him just for picking it up.
I probably fucked it up. I fucked
up everything. I don't know.
Do you know the other day I
actually called the periodic chart?
I called it the periodical. Yeah.
But that's the understand. I mean,
once it was a magazine bad,
no excuse.
It's like you're on a, you're on a
western. You call it a cow boy. You had,
how do you not fucking know? It shows
you the amount of fucking research I did.
Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 17th, 2010. How the hell are you?
How are you doing? How's
your work week? Uh, yeah.
Uh, I just, uh, this is one of
these days, right? Where I should,
I shouldn't,
you know something,
I'm gonna start having tap out days where
I don't do the fucking podcast because
I just got off a goddamn flight and
I am fucking exhausted. Once again,
I flew across this goddamn country,
and once again, it was the usual shit,
you know?
And I don't want to make fun of people
who are out of shape because they've got
a really heartfelt letter from somebody
who was opie saying, what the fuck?
Why you always trash and fat people?
Which I'm not.
That's all you're hearing because
that's the one that pulls on you, your,
your heartstrings, you know? And he writes
the whole fucking thing about how Blab,
Blab, a blue, a blue Yeti, Yada, Yada,
all this fucking shit, you know, you know,
everybody feels, everybody,
whatever group they're in,
they feel like they get it the worst.
You know, we get it the worst, you know,
even blah, blah, blah. When they blue
bell blue people least sake again,
right? But when they say, fuck,
I know, please. All right,
everybody thinks they got it the worst
and only one person is right. Okay.
So you got like a fucking 85%
chance of being wrong. You know,
nobody says, uh, you know, I'm going to
beat you like an obese stepchild. Do they?
They don't. They say, I'm gonna beat
you like a red headed stepchild.
They don't have kick a fat
Guy Day, do they? They have
kick a fucking redhead day,
a Ginger Day, right?
That's what they have.
Mia did make a fucking
video about, uh, uh, the,
the fucking genocide of obese
people did shake. No, she didn't.
She made it a red heads and it was funny.
Even a me,
I've been so beaten down as
a fucking redhead. Alright,
so quit your fucking wine.
You know, it's a fucking
podcast. I trash everybody.
Everybody's going down, including
myself. Everybody goes down this week,
okay.
If my Bruins are going to lose four games
in a fucking row and I got to listen
to Keith Robinson,
okay.
A guy who my entire time of knowing him,
every time I tried to bring up hug,
he goes out, Haka, sticks. I don't
like it. Nobody cares about hockey.
All of a sudden he gives a fuck.
You,
what's funny about that
fucking ignorant jackass?
He wouldn't even unknown that the
Bruins had a historical collapse of,
of, of, of, you know, I'm so
stupid of historical proportions.
He wouldn't even have known.
It's just that ESPN finally
showed some fucking hockey.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I was in Boston when it happened and I
really want to tell Philly people that
everybody was devastated.
But I gotta be honest with Ya.
I think maybe 11% of the city gave a shit.
And I'll tell you why,
because we haven't won in 38 fucking
years and we've pretty much sucked.
Um,
the,
Brian's kind of jumped the shark
when Ray Borg had to leave the team,
so he'd have an opportunity to win.
And then he went out to Colorado,
won the cup,
and then I know he,
he meant this in a good way.
He brought the cup to the city to sh
remind everybody in Boston what it looked
like.
And that was a low point, you
know, that was a low point.
And then we were up three games to one
against the Canadians and we couldn't
close them out.
We lost that fucking serious.
Then they blew up the
team and they traded away.
Gone Chad and fucking Joe and dude,
fuck him.
The couple of queers they leaders do.
So we trade away our best fucking
guys for what? Who Do we get?
We got the fucking baby face Magoo.
We ended up trading to fucking Toronto.
That's the only thing I got.
I got right now we've got the number
one pick, fulfill fucking castle.
That's all I got right
now. But um, anyways,
uh, I dunno what happened and that
series, all of a sudden they just stay,
just fucking sucked.
It wasn't like they weren't even trying.
They weren't even fucking, they
were just standing there going, wow,
look at the flyers. Jesus
Christ. Can that guys skate? Oh,
hang on a second. I'm going to
try to clear it out of the zone.
And the guy would take a slap shot at,
he couldn't even get it.
He couldn't even clear it
out of the fucking zone.
It would go like sideways into the boards.
Jesus Christ. And now my God, that fucking
Mac Davis looking jackass, Hartnell,
whatever the fuck his name is,
he was funny.
But Hartnell is after the game when he's
not, when he's not wearing a helmet,
he looks like a scary son of
a bitch like Jesus Christ.
Did that guy just come out of the woods,
you know?
Yeah.
Does it does, does, you know he
fucking, he just, he just looks like,
I don't know what he looks like. He looks
like a mountain man. He puts that in,
that helmet on. All of a sudden he looks
like he's in blades of glory, you know,
and he fucking guy can't even skate every,
every time he goes to make a pass he
falls down. But the fuckers there though,
tapping it in
Danny Bay or all those fucking assholes.
Congratulations Philly.
You guys totally deserve it. Uh, you know,
unlike the bro Wins, you didn't quit.
You kept playing the game. Yeah. Dot.
I don't know what happened that actually
the Bruins play the game right through
game four and they played the first period
of game seven and a little bit of the
third period.
You know,
and I know this sounds like I'm
taking away from the flyers, but dude,
they were just standing there and they
had one line that would actually go out
and start checking some of the flyers.
And when they did,
all of a sudden we were getting, we were
getting opportunities and it's like,
why wouldn't you continue doing
that? Was, is that crazy? Well,
not yet another job. Craig g head on the
bench. Did he also sit on the bench go,
Oh yeah guys, by the way, don't forget
to play hockey when you're out there.
And uh, when they're, when they're
around our net, they have the puck.
It's usually a good thing to
try to, you know, disrupt them.
Trying to put it into the net rather
than just standing there and waiting for
them to shoot it into the neck,
into the net.
So you then can whack your stick on
the ice and frustration. Oh jeepers,
they did it again. Golly, Gee,
Gee Wiz. I was fucking brutal.
It's bad enough. I had to sit
there and watch the Bruins lose.
But I was in Boston,
which means,
and this is a great thing
about fucking being in Boston,
is you guys know how I feel about
Dan Shaughnessy. Okay. The Guy,
he knows baseball, I'll give, you know, I
will give him that. But other than that,
he has made a fucking career on misery.
The guy loves misery is any
fucking misery to be found.
I don't give a fuck if somebody's
playing highlight or stick ball.
He's going to be there to write a fucking
story and the great thing is is he
doesn't even have the decency to know
what God damn thing about the sport.
All he's gotta do is just talk about this
misery that's about ready to happen or
is happening and then somehow
tie it in to fucking game.
Six of the 1986 red sox met series.
That's what the fuck he did with hockey.
If anybody who lives in Boston still
has ios going to grab one of the globe's
Boston Globes.
It's fucking hilarious.
I was saying it the night when we lost
and I was in a bar with like eight other
people.
It was more fucking flat screens on than
they were fucking Bruins fans at that
point. Right? Typical of all cities
at Dewald that die hard.
It meant die.
Everybody's fucking die hard
when they win a championship.
All of a sudden when they shit the bed,
four games in a row, you don't do it.
I'm kind of into the Celtics
cutting into the Celtics course.
You are you like a winter,
don't you?
MMM.
But I was literally standing there going,
you watch this guy, he'll somehow to do,
you know, he'll bring it around to the
curse of the bay, which of course he does.
And the great thing is,
is he does not know shit about hockey.
All he did was he looked at the
box score to see who scored when,
just so you could be,
and it's 1748 of the second period when
a fucking Hartnell shot the puck in the
net debt. So he could then be
like, uh, it was quieter in the,
in the garden than it was in Fenway back
and fucking puppet with Mookie Wilson.
He, ah, you guys are the worst. He's the
fucking worse. And he's got, he just,
I don't know.
I just want to understand how that guy
still has a job and why people in Boston
continue to buy his books
about fucking misery.
Okay.
You know,
he's such a pussy.
Anytime anything remotely bad
starts to happen in Boston sports,
he always got it. Oh my
God, what's going to happen?
Yeah,
it's, it's, it really is that how
you fucking approach, you know?
Yeah.
Whatever the fucking word is for
adversity. Adversity, that's the word.
That's how you approach it.
It isn't,
you wouldn't have gotten to the level
that you're at as a sports writer and
being on ESPN if that's how you
approach adversity. So stop to eat.
You don't use your fucking lazy.
Learn about the Goddamn game before you
write another one year lazy ass fucking
articles.
Dan Shaughnessy,
you want to see what this guy looks
like? I'll tell you right now, just go,
go to fucking, uh, the
[inaudible] podcast.com.
Get on my nice fucking photo.
Put up a him this week.
That noodle hair looking jackass.
Do you know,
I remember like a year after the red sox,
after they came back being
down four games to none.
You know, not against some sad
sack fucking team that barely met,
made the God damn play offs.
It doesn't have a fucking score.
They came back against a 210 $200 million
fucking team with like four or five
first ballot hall of
famers. We go on and, and,
and when the God damn world series
the very next year in September,
we got a couple of injuries.
We had like a six or seven
game lead against the Yankees
and all of a sudden the
Yankees come on and we start to lose a
little bit and this fucking idiot writes,
the curse is back. You can feel
it. It's back. It's in the water.
You know, it's the curse of
what Dan of course of what?
2004 the worth of the
fucking 1111 month curse.
The curse of what that,
that no one wants to buy your
stupid fucking book about misery.
Is that what it is? I
Dunno, I got a admit.
I think that was the worst part about
the Bruins losing four games in a row
cause it was for the fucking life on me.
I still don't hate the flyers.
I actually liked Carsello. I really liked
him and I hate the fucking Canadians.
I hate the Canadians. In of a
flyer fan gave me shit. I mean I,
I'd just sit there and take it.
Canadian fed gave me shit.
I'm not going to take it cause I'll
tell ya at the end of the fucking day,
that Flyer Fan, he's from the United
States. That's a fellow countrymen.
So all he's going to do
is trashed the Bruins.
He's not going to trash the good old USA.
That's why I don't like the Canadice.
Why I hate to Canadians fans the most.
They fucking trash my team and my country.
I'll tell you right now,
I won't stand for it with their
little pointy little French noses,
they appoint a little French noses.
Huh? Talking about yesteryear,
I'll walking around with that high school
fucking Letterman jackets up on how
they used to dominate the league 30
fucking years ago may tell you summary now
Canadians,
you guys can fucking slide all over the
ice block and as many shots as you like
cause you goaltender actually sucks.
If he's any fucking good.
Why you guys flopping around like a
bunch of goddamn flounders every time
someone takes a fucking wrist shot.
Oh my God,
whatever. Am I really trashing
teams that are still in it?
I'm going to shut the fuck up
now. What am I going to do? Okay.
What goes around comes around.
I've talked a lot of shit.
My teams have won a bunch
of championships. We deserve
some sort of, you know,
it's the balance, Dan Shaughnessy.
It's the balance. Okay?
He can't win all those
fucking championships in five
years and not expect to get
kicked in the seeds as a sports fan.
All right, but do me a fucking favor.
Don't write any more articles about
hockey because you don't know a fucking
thing about it with your
glancing at the box score.
Curse of the Babe Horse
Shit that you wrote.
Yeah,
they should surround this.
You know what they should do
with all those globe though?
That piece of shit article he wrote,
they should snip it all out.
The tie him to a stake and use that as
a stuff that you use to start a fire.
Whatever that word is.
What does that word come on?
Help me out here that we're to use when
you stoke a fire with something gives
with a k, doesn't it kill in a kit,
Caitlin, our country. Something. I don't.
What the fuck it is? Jesus
Christ. I know. I don't, you know.
Okay.
If you gave me a three games to none lead
with like fucking six of my friends I
used to play pond hockey with, we
could have one, one fucking game.
Jesus Christ
just fucking stupid and around
standing around. Nothing
went up. Three games,
three goals to none in game seven.
Then all of a sudden they score the flyer
score one goal and then they go back
to that pussy hockey again.
He's good to go.
Do you think they're going
to score another one?
It was, it was pathetic. And uh,
I dunno, I am ashamed. I'm ashamed.
I'm ashamed of my team, but I still love
him and I'm still wearing my and shit.
I don't give a fuck, you know? Okay.
It's a fuck. Lose three games in row.
Four games in a row. Yeah. Why would
you give a shit, you know, you know,
I know.
I like how these idiots are sitting and
talking about hockey right now going
like, you know, and it's wide open this
year. It's fucking wide open. You know,
they'll,
they'll though number one sheet to sheet
three sheet for she is fucking gone.
Yeah. That's because the two teams
that are left beat those teams. Stupid.
All right, well actually now the
Bruins beat the fucking third seat,
whatever I'm just saying.
And all of a sudden people don't have
the Canadians like they'd like to add
still an eighth see team. They are
still an AFC team, but you know,
they'd beat the capitals and the penguins.
So I would have to think that they
are odds on favorite to win it. And
I know this is boring the
shit out of everybody.
I've literally talked about hockey
for 15 fucking minutes. Have I? Ah,
fuck you guys. I don't give a shit.
All right. In this next round,
I am for the Black Hawks and I am for,
and uh,
I am for the flyers.
My nightmare.
Finals obviously is the Canadians for
San Jose because I hate both of those
teams. I respect San Jose. I went there,
there actually it's a hockey town.
They fucking love that team. Even now,
even though they fucking choke every year.
But I got to, I just don't like
how they, you know, they annoy me.
Okay.
San Jose.
And they annoy me because they remind
me of how annoying my French am,
how my franchise never
fucking signs anybody.
And they somehow sign everybody in there
and an under the fucking cap. But, uh,
I gotta go for the Black Hawks because
they haven't won it since 61 at, uh,
so I'm pulling for that team and uh,
and then I got to pull for the
flyers because, uh, I dunno, I,
she always have like the flyers. I
have to admit, I always liked him.
I liked the fights back in the
fucking day. Oh. And speaking of that,
I remember that shit
before this series started,
they got this new show
and on the versus network,
this round table of
like for regular dudes.
And then we'll have like some
big sports star. Come on.
I'm not saying if it's a good show,
a bad show, but I saw somebody on,
I believe it was that show going
like a Bruins verse. Flyers. Oh God,
this is going to be a blood bath.
Okay.
Just for the fucking record for
people who don't fucking watch hockey,
it's not 1979 anymore.
All right. And the Bruins,
it flyers just played seven games,
seven games,
I believe.
Two of which that went into overtime.
I'm already trying to block the whole
memory that's series out and there wasn't
one fucking fight.
There wasn't even at any cheap shot.
There wasn't.
I can't remember if,
I don't mean I wasn't really paying
attention with the Bruins then I'm gonna
want one point. Mac Davis there
got got to stick to his face,
but just cause the dude was trying to
lift the stick up and he missed it.
You know, we've got a couple of
fucking stitches. Yeah. Ah, fuck it.
All right. That's it there.
I addressed it. So, uh,
okay.
I Dunno, whatever. I heard there's a
really good guy in the draft next year.
Taylor Hawkins. Is that his name? Was
that the drummer from the foo fighters?
I can't fucking remember. I don't know
any of that shit. I'm just hoping. Look,
this is all I wanted. All I
wanted was us to fucking, uh,
after we beat the, the, uh,
the fucking savers just to have a good
showing in the next round. They don't,
we fucking lose. I don't
care. I know we're rebuilding,
but did you have to shit the
bed to that fucking level?
All right. Whatever. This is the Monday
morning podcast. This is a, a, a,
a special hockey edition of the,
uh, the Monday morning podcast.
Um, all right. I don't even know
where the fuck to go from here. Uh,
how about a youtube video? I might've
even hype this thing last week. Uh,
this is one of these things.
Um, uh, just search this.
Don't fall asleep at a baseball
game. Just watch that. And uh,
for all you women out there,
you'll realize how much fun it is to be
a guy when you watch this video. Like,
we can have fun when there's absolutely
nothing going on. And not only that,
it's fucking hilarious. Are you saying
that we can't have fun? Actually,
I think I kind of am,
but I think the reality is,
is I just don't understand your
fun. So I want this, this fall.
You all the ladies out there. Uh, why
don't you watch that video. Okay. And,
uh, I challenge you not to fucking
laugh. Well, I guess you won't. Yeah,
you won't laugh.
You guys are great liars and your
greater controlling your fucking emotion,
so you won't, but I'm just telling
you it's a funny fucking video.
All right now and, and if you want
to show me how women have fun,
you show me a video of women doing
like absolutely nothing is going on,
but it's still fucking hilarious.
Find one of those on youtube and I'll
have a little more respect for whatever it
is that you do because my
references are, I guess, uh,
sex in the city.
You know?
Is that even a reference? I don't
know. Just the women I've dated,
I've always watched that fucking show.
Okay.
You know, can you believe in and make it
an another fuck? I'm one of those movies.
They make it another sex and the city
movie and now they're going to Egypt.
At what point are they just going
to let that fucker think die?
Why don't they just have the cast of the
drew Carey show show up and that's what
they should do.
And then turn it into colleague Leah
and somebody gets fisted and then just
fucking ended.
Could somebody just end?
This really has nothing to do with
either one of those franchises.
It has to do with my fucking
jet lag and uh, and the Bruins.
Complete fucking collapse.
Oh, fuck it. Hearts.
Ah, Jesus. All right.
You know, I drank a
lot this past week. Um,
this is, this is, I'd realize something.
This is a big test in a relationship.
I don't give a fuck how beautiful you
think a woman is, how much you love her,
how much she makes her heart go pitter
patter your heart. Go pitter patter. The,
the true test of whether
or not you can stand.
You're going to be able to stand the
woman that you think you're going to spend
the rest of your life with is if you can
handle what her voice sounds like when
she's trying to yell
over the noise in a bar.
If you can handle what that sounds like
and you just fill in your funny punchline
right there because evidently I don't
have the fucking energy to do it.
What have I just talked for hockey
for 17 minutes to my fucking self.
I trashed Dan Shaughnessy.
I told the fat guy to stand down.
You know fucking people want sympathy
cause they always eat the last cookie
rally self as sons of bitches.
Um,
all right.
You know what I'm gonna do this week?
I'm going to tap out by reading some
fucking emails from some of my listeners.
Oh, here's something I learned
this week. Did you know though,
the natural color of rubber is white?
Did you know that?
I didn't know that went
by this guy's place.
He had this collection of fucking cars
and old motorcycles and I love that shit
cause I wish I was good
at working on cars.
You know what I mean by I wish
I had like a set set a ranches.
Now you are working on a car,
you know,
greasy rag in my back pocket.
I could fucking, you know,
find that right spot and the jukebox
and make it play a song, you know,
but I can't, you know, I kill and you
know what? Fuck you, I could, I could,
if I took some time,
I watched a couple youtube videos
and he gave me a regular old engine,
I could do some shit. I could figure
out some stuff maybe in another life.
I don't know what. So anyways,
this guy had an old motorcycle guy,
like I was going at, you know, all white
tires on it. And he goes, that's actually,
cause it was like, uh, one of the
original motorcycles, I guess,
where you couldn't even fucking stop the
thing. It just had to run out of gas.
You just turned it on
and it just went full on.
And I guess the way to slow it down was
you had to reach down and put your hand
over, uh, the carburetor or
something, whatever the fuck. Yeah.
With the air goes in the old is that
what happens? Oxygen and gas mixture.
He just put it over there.
You sort of smothered it and that's
how you slowed it down. But anyways,
these tires,
I know that's completely wrong.
So you fucking gearheads can trash man.
I don't give a fuck. You doing a podcast,
you've got a podcast on how the original
motorcycles run. I didn't think you did.
So go fuck yourself.
All right.
Don't you clean out under your nails so
your wife doesn't get another fucking
infection. That was brutal. Um, anyways,
when you finger blaster just to spell
it out to the fucking nerds in the
cubicles, um, how do I
know that? I forget how.
I know that.
I overheard you a fucking dirty broad
talking about that in a bar one night.
Anyways. Yeah, I guess the
original color of of rubber,
it's natural color is white.
I didn't know that.
So all these years when I was
looking at white wall tires,
I thought that they just took like a
strip of white paint or whatever and they
painted them white and the
natural color of rubber was black,
but it is white and you would
think I would have noticed,
you know all the years of looking at
cars that side swiped curves, you know,
and hacking up their tires.
It was always white underneath.
You'd think that I would
have noticed but I never did.
So here's my question for
all you gearheads out there.
Why did they paint it black?
You know
anybody,
I don't know.
Fucking know.
Where am I going with this shit.
You know what that actually reminds me.
Have you ever see like when somebody
dies on a bicycle and then they have that
entire ghost white bicycle
that they have there,
that creepy one with the flowers.
I saw another one.
It absolutely gives me fucking chills.
It's my closest sixth sense moment
that I'll ever have in my life.
When they do that,
I don't for the fucking life of me
understand why they have to put the bike
there too. You just can't put a reef down.
Why do they have to do the whole bike?
What is,
who started that?
I know I talked about this on the opiate
Anthony show a couple of years ago,
but what the fuck?
Okay.
It still bugs me. It just
creeps me out that, you know,
he was on a bike and he died.
They don't have like drunk drivers,
you know, they smash into trees.
So you get hit by a drunk driver.
Do they frost out a fucking car,
you know,
mannequin underneath it and I, that's a
brutal job and I, you know what I mean?
It's just fucking creepy.
Fucking creepy.
Stop it. Some, you know, gets
hit on a bicycle, a wreath.
They're like a normal person.
Fucking sit there and don't you just put
the bike he got hit on with a bent up
tires and shit.
I knew it was going to be mean this week.
I'm tired and I'm fucking, my Bruins lost
four in a row. All right. Let me, uh,
try to get something positive here. I'm
literally in May Day, May Day right now.
All right. Hi, Bill.
My fiance and a couple of our friends
saw you and Atlantic city this past
Saturday. You be on hysterical. I got a
picture with you, but Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
I recently quit my job as
a photo retoucher for this
high end retouching company
by my job was to make models
thinner and more beautiful,
but also sit on my ass 10 to 12 hours
per day like a robot. It was brutal,
but what could help me through it was
listening to your Monday morning podcast.
I would sit there in a silent
room hysterically laughing,
often needing to throw my
headphones off because I was crying.
I was laughing so hard. In fact, I got
in trouble once for laughing so much.
I needed to be more and people told me
I need to be more serious about my job
for thanks. So thanks for doing
what you do. Uh, well thank you.
I don't know why I saved that podcast.
That email made me feel good.
And you know what,
I saved that before the Bruins lost
four games in a fucking row. So I was,
I was in a better mood.
Yeah.
All right, let's read another one. See
if I can get out of this. I'm a really,
really bombing right now. Ah,
Bill. Hi. I love your work.
I don't know if you've
covered this before, uh,
as I found out about you, uh, uh,
but what are your views on celebrity
adoption? I think I saw Sandra Bullock's,
uh, has just done this, but to be honest,
she doesn't have the profile orange or
indeed now the father figure to really
pull off this adoption seriously though.
I think it's sick.
They find the most fashionably deprived
countries, countries. Oh my God,
I can't even read this week
too. All right, Bill, come on.
Get your shit together. Right. They find
the most fashionably deprived countries.
Uh,
that doesn't even make sense.
You mean the most popular ones to give
a fuck about? Is that what you mean?
They take the prettiest kid
in the orphanage and then
dress him up at the baby
gap and carry them around
like a fucking Chihuahua.
It's like by absorbing them into
this plastic la bullshit lifestyle,
they pretend they're actually doing
something about the root cause of global
poverty.
When Angelina Jolie adopts a 56 year
old Serbian war widow with a drinking
problem, takes her to Disney
world and lets her fuck Brad Pitt,
I might then buy it. All
right. That's all hilarious.
Even though I didn't read
it correctly. Plot, um,
um, you know, this is
just this classic thing.
Where do you ever notice
when you do something good?
If people find out about it,
they have to trash it on some level. I
mean, you know, I get what you're saying.
I've actually done bits about that.
Uh, you know that they, you know,
I actually did something
about Paris Hilton,
something bedazzleing some
African kid making her,
making the kid match her
phone or something like that
and she left it behind in
a club was one of those topical jokes.
I don't think I ever did on TV, but uh,
she is kind of doing something about,
you say she's not doing
something about poverty.
Okay.
She just took a kid who wasn't poverty.
All right,
I'm going to play the devil's advocate.
Okay.
And put them in a fucking
house with running water and
is now going to feed them.
You know, I think a lot of times
when people do good shit like this,
it annoys people because it reminds
us that we're not doing shit about it.
Maybe that's why I make fun of them.
Okay,
well maybe it's that thing,
you know,
he didn't pray in public so everybody
can see how fucking holy there.
I don't understand why they can't just
adopt a kid personally and just fucking
do it and then that's it. You don't hold
it up on the cover of people magazine.
Look now I'm agreeing with you. I'm going
to go a little skit. So on this one.
Yeah. Sandra, why do you get to
hold the fucking thing up? You know,
I don't fucking know,
but she is doing something about poverty.
That kid was fucking broke and really
sick of all you people who don't live in
Los Angeles talking
about how plastic La is.
And then you're acting like nobody lies
in nobody's full of Shit and you're
fucking hometown. Just be honest.
They're better looking than you.
They have more money than you.
Okay.
And they're living the life that
you fantasize about. All right.
I'm man enough to admit that
I was actually mad enough
to move out here and have
the audacity to think that I could live
that life on some level that's helped us
fucking pathetic. I am. Um, look,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I ever did something like that,
I think it's a great thing
to do. You know, I, you know,
and considering the world is fucking
overpopulated and where we're headed
towards major food shortages that nobody
wants to deal with because everybody's,
you know,
I haven't had a boy yet,
so I'm going to try to have another
kid or I haven't had a girl yet,
so I'm gonna try to have another kid.
You know,
I read something about this
guy in rolling stone today.
I ain't know his fucking name,
but he's some legendary soul
singer that I've never heard of.
So I don't think he's at legendary cause
I think it would have heard about him.
I think when you're like, seriously,
well I guess if he was an icon,
I would've heard about them. Whatever.
I'll give it to him. He's legendary.
The fucking guy had 21 kids who
then spawned 90 grandchildren.
Um, and you know, I'm going to
fucking call it first in the future.
That's going to be fucking
considered illegal.
Like what that guy did is basically he
had his own major fucking oil spill into
the ocean, but rather than
the ocean, it, it was on land.
You know, his fucking seaman. What,
just fucking leaking out 5,000 gallons
of fucking day. Just like that.
God Damn Crater.
The bottom of the ocean.
You think he didn't just on a couple of
ducks, make a 21 fucking kids. They did.
That guy should be in fucking
jail for that 21 fucking kids.
I mean, you guys are at work. Can
you name 21 people you work with?
Can you imagine if that was your fucking
kid? 21 kids. He has 90 grandchildren.
There's no,
do you understand?
He doesn't know the names
of all of his grandchildren.
Oh, maybe he does. But in
order to make room for that,
you'd have to forget half your friends'
names. I know the names of 90 people.
What the fuck? I probably know the
names of 90 professional athletes.
I'm really underestimating the power
of the human brain. But what the fuck
one fucking guy's dick with
two balls is far as we know,
created that,
that fucking ecological disaster.
You know, what I love about rolling stone
is, is, is they got in, in that, um,
in this week's issue where they have
Keith Richards on the cover yet again,
you've got to love rolling
stone every fucking three weeks.
If tonight just have some teeny bopper
on there. They're still mining the 60s.
Yeah.
The exile on Main Street reissue.
I love this shit were like,
the original artists were like
back in the day were just like,
do you want to release this song now?
It's sucks compared to the rest of the
shit. And then 40 fucking years later,
okay,
when you want to buy another yacht,
you start putting out shit that you didn't
feel was worthy of releasing when you
were at your peak.
You know,
I don't fucking know that Tupac
Shit that Jimi Hendrix Shit,
the fucking, uh, I don't know.
There's very few that I can think of
that they actually reissued that were
actually worth listening to.
I'll tell you one that in recent years,
this past decade was led Zeppelin when
they came out with that concert film of
them at Royal Albert Hall. And, um,
you know, all that concert footage,
that shit was great. That actually
was great stuff. But they, but they
also weren't, why were you guys red?
Led Zeppelin is repackaged. They act for
and what the fuck am I talking about?
Every two years they,
they, they, whatever,
10 years they do the new digital
remaster of whole lot of love.
You know what I mean? I don't know
what the fuck I'm talking about.
Talk about rolling stone. Okay.
So getting back to that shit,
they actually do a story
on this guy who's like, um,
he goes into like,
you know,
war torn countries and he liked buys up
land and he makes deals with basically
war criminals or,
or whatever to buy up land because
he knows that this unbelievable like,
um,
okay,
food crisis is common.
It's fucking scary.
And this guy is out there having 21
goddamn kids who then go on to have 90
fucking grandchildren. And uh, you know,
it's the kind of shit that, you know,
that like, that's it. Morning
talk show stuff. You know,
like nobody would even even sit there
and talk about how fucking reprehensible
that is.
I Dunno.
Look, I think I should get a
tax break at my fucking age.
All right.
I to be able to drive a full size
fucking hummer with no muffler down the
Goddamn street.
The fact that I have not procreated and,
and just basically, you know, right now
I'm, I'm basically doing what people,
well related to Hitler or doing,
I'm letting my bloodline die off.
If you guys ever heard of that shit,
then evidently the relatives of a,
you know, like his fucking great,
great grand nephews or whatever
or whatever the fuck they are.
This evidently like
two or three more left.
They live in Long Island and they
all made a pact not to get married.
Okay.
And uh,
okay.
And just let the bloodline die off because
they're so afraid that whatever made
Hitler so fucked up, we'll let, I
mean they talking like some omen shit,
you know,
like you'd be pushing you a little baby
Hitler on his swing and all of a sudden
your nanny's standing on a rooftop,
you know,
jumping off because like subliminally
this little fucking kid told him to with
is fucked up. Pew prepub pre
pubescent mustache. Yeah.
I fucking hate this podcast.
I really would erase this thing
if I wasn't 35 fucking minutes in.
I really would. I really would,
but I can't because I can't,
I can't go through this fucking shit
again. I can't read this stuff. All right.
Well anyway, I can't remember
what my fucking point was. Look,
I think Sandra Bullock did a good thing.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, why she did it.
I don't fucking know. Okay.
But I'm going to give it the benefit
of the doubt that she did a good thing.
But just notice anytime anybody does
something, even remotely consider it.
Like how fucked up that
makes people around him.
At no point did Sandra
Bullock, oh, I did this.
You should do this to look
what a great person I am.
Granted she's holding the fucking kid up
like a Goddamn bowling trophy on people
magazine. You know what?
You're fucking right.
But I kind of relate to her cause
like when people find out, I,
I when I first bought my Prius,
I got a ton of shit from people.
What did you do that for?
Who you think you think you were
actually making a difference?
You know, like they got all
fucking defensive. I'm like, dude,
I'm not saying you can't drive with
the fuck you drive. I bought it for me.
I fly every other fucking weekend. I put
my own hole and the fucking ozone layer.
I'm trying to do something,
something, you know,
to not be a total douche. Right.
That's all I'm doing here.
I'm not saying you're
doing anything wrong.
I'm not saying you can't drive
a fucking car with a v eight.
I'll give a fuck what you do.
Get in your car and get away from me.
Fucking asshole.
Um, I dunno. So that's what
I have to say about that.
I don't know if it made any sense.
Okay.
I Dunno. I got no idea. All right.
Uh, here we go, Bill Birth. Wow.
What do you want to ask me? Ask
Bill. Um, oh, here's one for you.
I got it right here.
This is the one that's going to pull
this fucking podcast out of the God damn
mud bill on 21 years old and
attend a big 10 university.
I'm not the best looking guy in the world,
but I think I'm,
what I lack in that department is made
up with high amounts of intelligence and
charm.
Wow.
You just really sound like a sweaty
fat guy with a lampshade on his head,
but I'm not going to judge. Um,
that's another fact. I joke.
Maybe I do have something with,
I don't know.
You know what it is because I'm constantly
in contact with those fucking people
to Goddamn epidemic out there.
You know,
I had the aisle seat and uh,
I was back towards the back of
the plane today and you know,
the aisle seats great.
You could stretch out a little bit.
When you want to get up and take a leak,
you don't have to step over people.
There's a lot of fucking advantage just
to have and if when you start getting
towards the back of the plane and that
becomes that moment where everybody has
to go to the bathroom
and aligned develops.
The problem is is as these round people
are trying to get past each other,
there's not enough room.
So what ends up happening is one of these
douchebags stomach slash unit ends up
on your shoulder as they lean a little
bit into your fucking airspace so the
other fatty can get by him.
It's fucking guy was enormous on the
God damn plane to the point I felt like
heat coming off of him. Do you want to
stand like how out of shape that is?
It was like,
you know you could like like earth,
the planet fucking earth.
How the co it's core is still on fire.
Okay.
All right. I really didn't
want to attack fat. People get,
I know I'm going to lay off. I'm going
to lay off for the rest of the podcast.
That's it. That's it. God bless Ya. I
know it's a problem. I'm room for you.
Do the right thing. Have a salad.
I got my problems. Look at me,
you know, whatever. All
right, here we go. Uh, anyway,
you fucking try to get through this.
All right. I'm not the best looking guy,
but oh boy. Can I tell a joke? I'm not
just patting myself on the back there. Uh,
there is a reason I'm standing it
all right. For the past two years,
I've been doing horribly in school.
Oh, Jesus. Now I just trashed this guy.
He's going to fucking kill himself.
I've been doing horribly
in school dealing with, uh,
things that are pretty depressing,
but because of this,
I've had to come up with clever ways of
trying to pass classes in an effort to
not get dropped from school. Uh, as such,
my strategy has been to pick a teaching
assistance that are females in order to
try and charm my way into passing the
classes while putting in as little work as
possible as I possibly could do.
Do you have a future?
I'm gonna tell you this right now,
son. Don't give up on yourself.
You have a fucking future.
If you've figured out a way
to pass classes by doing
that charming people while
doing little or no work,
I'm telling you there was a
corner office waiting for you.
So don't, don't give up on
yourself. All right, here we go.
What the fuck am I? A bit up a
little work as possible. Granted,
I am well aware that manipulating slash
charming women into giving me good
grades is fucked up and not the most
practical way of going about doing things,
but it fucking works. Hey Dude, they
do that to get a free drink out of you.
You don't don't if there's no shame
in that fight, fire with fire.
I'm totally what this guy.
However,
my lack of foresight is very much
evident now is something you probably saw
coming happened. I fell
hard for my ta, this,
the teaching assistant this semester
from day one. I was attracted to her.
This is a good story so far. How
could this go off the rails? Um,
let's continue. And a while. I do
try and charm her every chance I get.
In an odd way,
me being so attracted to tour has fueled
my melt motivation to study and show
off the fact that I can easily acer class.
I go every week to her office hours
I go to are,
but I go every week to her office
hours she holds for students,
which are about two
hours and nobody ever go.
So it ends up just being her and me
flirting with one another the entire time.
However,
maybe it's because I'm a male or maybe
it's because I'm so attracted to her,
but I didn't notice the huge
wedding ring on her finger. Oh,
geesh. [inaudible] we go, everybody,
it's going this way again.
A lot of guys out there, if I can
do on a wrong turn, all right.
But I didn't notice her huge wedding
ring on her finger up until about a month
ago. Uh, I bet in a class
now for about four months. I
brought it up to her saying,
Holy Shit,
you're married.
And her response is what holds my hopes.
Okay.
Before I get into her response,
dude, you're full of shit.
There's no way for four fucking
months you didn't notice her,
her fucking wedding ring.
This is you toning down the fact that
you knew right out of the gate she was
fucking married. She had a huge wedding
ring. He didn't, you didn't notice.
Okay, maybe you're young, maybe you
don't look, but how do you miss that?
And then you said, Holy
Shit, you're, you're married.
That sounds like a great setup line
to get the response that you got.
So the guy says, Holy Shit,
you're married, Huh? And she goes,
he goes in a response is what holds up
my hopes in an astonish almost forgetful
way. She replies, Oh yeah.
Wow. Okay Dude, you're in. All right.
I'm not saying you should do it, but if
your, if your question is, am I n Urn,
mmm.
Census, revelation. I have been
continuing to bring up, uh,
as much as I can about her husband. If
nothing else for comparison. All right,
this is getting twisted. Dude, don't
bring up her husband. Just go in.
If you've got a Banger, just
fucking banger. You know, does,
does he look good better in a
jacket? Did I do, I do. I look better
the more I bring it up though,
the more it seems like she regrets
getting married at such a young age.
She got married at 23 and now she's 25.
This is my predicament.
My parents got divorced when
I was six because my bald,
childish fat piece of Shit. Father cheated
on my mother with their best friend.
So I have reservations about
dating a married woman. Uh,
it doesn't sound that horrible.
While I'm trying to justify,
doesn't sound that horrible while I'm
trying to justify attempting to date a
married woman. But it's
like you said, what is it?
75% of marriages go right
down the shitter right now.
I have no problem with waiting it out. But
I'll ask my question in two forms. One,
what would you suggest doing to try and
feel out the likelihood of this marriage
lasting? And two, if
it's clear that it's not,
which with not much prying done on
my part is clear to see it won't.
What can I do to perhaps bring about
the breakup as soon as possible?
All right, dude, these are the questions
of a 21 year old. Okay? First of all,
you don't date a married woman.
All right? You want a banger?
Go ahead and bang her.
She actually wants you to bang her because
she needs some sort of spark to get
up her courage to get out of that fucking
marriage that she clearly didn't want
to be. And um, I'm telling you right now
as, as she was walking down the aisle,
her brain was screaming, what the fuck
are you doing? All right, this is, uh,
you know,
she got married at 23.
I don't know what our dating
experience was before that.
Maybe she doesn't know
how to get out of it.
She seems like someone who does not know
how to get out of a relationship now,
what kind of relationship she has.
It doesn't sound like an abusive one.
It sounds like a,
I don't know.
She just got involved in something
and then she just got into deep.
Didn't know how to get out of it.
The dude had met her family.
When are you getting married?
And she just fucking went down that
fucking water slide. She did not get off.
And now this is her deal.
So this is the deal, dude,
you're going about this the
wrong way. I, first of all,
you shouldn't fucking do it,
all right?
You shouldn't do it because you're,
you're,
you're dealing with the
married fucking woman here.
There's somebody who wanted to spend the
rest of his life with her, all right?
And you're delving into
that shit so you don't,
and you want to tear it and he'll do,
you don't know what this
girl's going to do. Okay?
She could be using you for the courage,
right?
Go out and Fucking Bang you alright?
And a God damn rainstorm come
home like a drown fucking rat,
just so he can start the
conversation and be like, honey,
where the fuck are you bed?
So she could just flip out and be like,
I just fucked one of my students.
You know,
just so she could just get out.
Whatever.
How many fucking years
she's been sitting on?
I don't want to be with you anymore.
All right?
And I'm telling you, if you, if
you meet a psycho fucking woman,
they have a really bad fucking habit of
doing something really fucked up with
the person that they're
in a relationship with.
And then they feel guilty
afterwards so they have to confess.
And then, you know, the
guy can't hit the woman.
So guess who he's going to come and hit.
You know that you just blew up his fucking
life. So you shouldn't fuck this girl.
But I'm telling you right now, dude, if
you're got a Banger, just fucking Banger,
but you wanting to date a married fucking
woman is completely the wrong fucking
thing to do.
I like,
I just gave you the green light to go
ahead and bang her if you want. You know?
I mean,
I'm not telling you to do that,
but I'm telling if you're going to choose
one or the other, he got three choices.
Don't fucker. That's what I'm
telling you to do. All right?
But if you're going to go with,
if you're going to go to the dark side,
there's Darth Vader and there's
Darth Vader light here. Okay?
And I'm saying to,
to take the less calories of evil here.
What you should do is just try to bang
her. Do not try to date this girl, okay?
This girl isn't ready to date.
She doesn't know what the fuck she wants.
She Shell, she so doesn't know
what she wants and she show her.
So has an inability to communicate
what it is that she wants,
that she actually married somebody
she doesn't want to be married to.
She's just sitting there
with its screaming inside.
I don't want to maybe married you.
I don't want to be married.
I don't even married at this point in
my life. I don't want to have kids.
I'm not ready for this. I want to get the
fuck outta here. I want to, I want the,
you know what she needs to do.
She's break up with this guy and go get
an apartment and live by herself for a
good year and a half, two
fucking years, you know?
And Not really date anybody for a good
six fucking months. Cry this shit out.
Go to therapy,
figure out what's wrong with her.
Make a fucking list of what she
wants in life. She's got to do shit.
She needs to do that kind of work.
And you're trying to date this woman,
this fucking mess while she's still
married. Don't do it. All right.
Go charmed the shit out of somebody
else and, and try and bang them.
I'm telling you right now, do, don't
fucking do it. Don't do it. All right.
That's my advice to you.
Uh,
that's it. That's it. That's all I got to
say on that. Don't, don't fucking banger.
And if you do decide to Banger,
I mean you do decide to get with
a do not fucking data. Okay. Even,
even if I'm telling you,
dude,
you're going to fucking probably make
the wrong decision because you're young,
you're probably going to try and dater
cause you actually got feelings for all
right?
And then what she's going to do is she's
just going to use you to get over this
other guy before she dumps you and fucking
rips your heart out of your God damn
chest. That's what the, you're
going to be roadkill. All right?
Fortunately, you haven't banged her yet.
You know, all he got his feelings for.
So get out now,
dial it down a sir class.
Get on with your fucking life.
There's plenty of other fucking teachers'
assistants out there, that chicken bag,
all right? But that's not the move to
make. Good luck to you. It's your life.
You make your decisions,
but I'm telling you over and over again,
evidently I'm going to keep saying
the same thing over and over again.
Do not cease and desist.
Fuck that. Walk away.
Walk, Dude. You know, you don't want that
on your resume. You just don't. All right?
All right, trust me. Okay,
here we go. Asbell Ah,
this story is a little bit long. Um,
but I was out with the clothes. Oh,
Jesus. Here's another one. Oh,
Jesus. Um, the story's a bit long,
but in the end of your
podcast, but in the end, oh,
this is this fist that actually an
interesting one here. Okay, Bill,
this story is a bit long, but in the
end, your podcast makes a girl cry.
Okay? Somehow my podcast made
a girl cry. Okay, here we go.
I was out with a close friend and
his girlfriend, his girlfriend,
having some drinks and a
five bottles of wine later.
My friends girl brings up a point
about how pro athletes are overpaid.
I said, a yes, it is dumb to pay
someone $8 million to catch a football,
but if you think about everything else,
it's, it's, it is deserved. First off,
millions of people play plan there every
Sunday around watching these athletes
and since the industry is
a gold mine for the owners,
the talent gets paid a pretty
fair portion. Secondly,
virtually every man in America has
played organized sports at some point in
their lives. I think it's fair that
you are, if you are the absolute best,
it's something that every man
has tried to do in their lives.
You should get paid.
This isn't the high score and that
arcade game and your favorite pub.
Every man in America has put, put
some quarters in this, in this one.
I don't know. I think some of that left
out or that just read that bad. Anyway,
so I'm from that,
it quickly turned into an argument about
the fact that pro women don't get paid
that much, and that's where I
bowed out. I stopped and said,
Oh, you're one of those girls. I'm sorry,
but this conversation never
goes. Well Jesus, dude,
you're totally Batan or for a
fight. I love this guy. Okay. Uh,
she snapped back and said, no, no, no, no,
no. Say what? You're going to stay now.
Come on. You brought it up. Fucking
thay. She didn't say all that,
but I know she did. So he goes,
honestly, I tried to avoid
the issue. No, you didn't.
You baited her into it by saying, Oh,
you're one of those girls. I'm sorry,
but this conversation never
goes. Well, a classic,
what do they call that? We
had your fucking year. You
do the reverse sell. Yeah.
You don't want a car like this.
Then the, the, the, the, the,
the guy actually sells it himself. Um,
oh, there's my dog. Cleo, come over here.
Cleo audio. What's going
on? I just picked her up.
She was staying down at the dog.
He Super Eight. Look at you.
They gave you a little high top fade.
Denya trimmed underneath the belly.
Huh?
What's up buddy?
Little exhale into the
microphone. All right, here we go.
I fucking hate when a dog does that
lick my fucking toe.
It's weird.
It's creepy fucking moment.
That should not happen between an
animal and a human being. All right,
I'm continuing on. Yes. He basically,
you baited this woman to a fight, dude.
You know you did. I know you did. And
I love you for it and think it's great.
I love arguing with women like this too.
So anyways,
let's continue on and I'm not buying
your shit. Honestly. I tried to back out,
but she said, say what you're
going to say. So he goes, honestly,
I tried to avoid the issue. Uh, I did.
I will say that I am a bit of a massage.
A misogynist? Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
Dude. Okay. I had no idea.
Uh, but I know, uh, what not
to get into with feminists. Um,
plus she's my friend's girl.
Uh,
this is getting ugly and you're
drinking just can not end well.
But she forced me into the
argument after she heard me say,
after she heard me say to my friend,
why am I arguing with the
girl about sports? Dude,
you're being totally passive aggressive.
That's hilarious. Let me guess.
You said it like three feet from her ear.
Why am I arguing with the
girl about sports? I mean,
they don't know shit about
sports. You know? How did
they just make me a sandwich?
And then they fucking did he come back at
you and you and you act like, you know,
I tried to avoid it. Okay, here we go. So
I began, it began, here's the argument.
Uh, she told me, um, I played
high school, thought Garth,
I know sports.
This made me snap because she was
bringing up high school credits to me,
which people really don't do around
me. Uh, people don't do that around me,
I guess for good reason.
In high school I was ranked number one
in the state for three different sports
ranked nationally in football.
I was inducted to the high school football
hall of fame at the age of 21 played
division one ball on a full scholarship
and was projected to go seventh in the
draft until I blew me knee out.
I got to ask you a question dude.
Blew me knee out. Are you from
like England? We are playing footy.
We talk in soccer over there.
At this point I thought
you were like maybe that,
that guy that fucking running back there
that went to buffalo from Ohio state.
Um, no, but he did good. He did go
number one in the first round. Anyone.
He pretended to talk on
a cell phone to a team,
but he was really talking to his agent.
The fuck was that guy's name. Anyways. Um,
I don't, um, Willis mcgahee. All
right, continue bill. Fine. Um,
I don't bring this stuff up ever. So
she, uh, she might not have known,
but she baited me and I felt
like putting her in her place.
I was starting to get arrogant
but still making my point.
So you're basically telling her that
you were ranked number one in three
different sports and you would
have been seventh in the draft,
but you blow out your knee do it.
I wish I was there to see that.
That's a great one. I bet
that shut her down. Uh,
but she baited me and I felt
like putting her in a place,
I was starting to get arrogant now.
Not you dude, you're down to earth. Um,
but still making my point of why sports
are such a money grabber. I said,
over 60,000 people come out
every Saturday to, uh, every,
every over 60,000 people came out every
Saturday to watch what me and my friends
do athletically. And we weren't even
getting paid. She interrupted with,
I don't care.
Uh,
then she started talking
about women's soccer against.
So I interrupted her by saying I
have never played soccer in my life,
but I can guarantee you that
I am better at it than you are
dude,
where you blew you like leaning over a
table of coronas pointing in her face at
this, at this point, and are
you much bigger than her, her,
her fucking boyfriend that he
didn't try to step in? Oh God,
I wish you fucking made. This would've
been a great youtube video. Um, anyways.
Now what I meant by that was
I was probably twice as fast,
five times stronger and have enough
natural coordination to pick up soccer and
be as good, if not better at it than you,
because I'm a pretty high level athlete.
What she heard was all men are better
at sports than ever than every woman.
She got emotional,
but her anger held back the tears
while I was just trying to figure out,
while I was just trying to figure out
how the conversation got to this point.
Well, if you want to figure
out how it got to that point,
let's start with your opening line of
like, oh, you're one of those women,
I know enough not to get into Oregon with
the, with the fucking woman. Like you,
you know, come on dude.
You baited her into it.
You baited her into what you wanted
to have the argument because you love
yelling at women. And I relate.
I'm not judging you. Um, you know,
it's not like you're on people magazine
holding up the woman that you were
yelling at, cause you just adopted
her like Sandra Bullock liquid. I did.
Oh, Thong. Yay.
Um, she got emotional, but our anger
will held back on, tears it up a Da.
Finally my friends stepped in
and I settled down. Uh, she just,
she got silent for a bit,
but she sparked back up when
I brought up ed hardy shirts,
the ones that are so colorful
and bedazzled and Warren,
a couple of sizes too small by
dudes. Uh, she said, I don't got,
I don't get why guys wear stuff like that.
Girls don't like girls don't like it.
I came back as I came
back and said as before,
I agree that the shirts are dumb,
but girls actually do love that shit dude.
You just love fucking pissing off women.
That's what you do.
You're just arguing with this
woman on every fucking point.
That's what you're doing.
Um,
and I think it's fucking hilarious
cause I've done this. I am this guy.
Did I write this? That I get drunk and
send myself a fucking email anyways,
she replied with,
are you going to tell me that you
know more about girls than I do too?
Then I do also basically he said to
which I said yes and he finally admits,
I think I was trying to fight at this
point. We were on bottles seven of wine.
Uh, I said, you obviously know more
about what it's like to be a woman.
I'm sorry,
my screen just went blank.
You obviously know what moral it's
like to be a woman than me. Yeah.
But figuring out what girls want
in a man is our job as guys,
since I was 14 I've
been studying this shit.
I spent more time learning about
girls in college than I did about my,
about my degree. Uh, she
made some more dumb points,
mostly just angry at me saying,
well,
I don't like the shirts and I'm an
I'm a girl. So there you go. Anyways,
uh, you know how when you're
drunk you get better at arguing,
but Merce worse at, uh,
coming up with solid points.
I couldn't think of how to explain
this to her, but a classic bill,
Bill Burr Line came into my head.
I told her, you don't get it.
Men literally have to develop a
skill to get women to like them.
Uh, and then he writes, which
is a great line by the way,
but I may have taken it too far and he
goes on to say it's not love at first
sight and all that soulmate shit.
Men have to purposely take
steps to get you separate the,
to separate yourself from the crowd.
The feelings part,
the feelings part might
be out of your hands.
But to set up those things is an easy,
unless you're wearing some sparkly shirt.
Most of my closest friends wear
those shirts and trust me it works.
I'm not saying you're stupid. Uh, I may,
I may have said that part a little
sarcastically course she wore. Um,
but let's pretend that me
and my friends have only s.
Let's pretend that me and my friends
have only slept with 50 girls each.
That means I've partly
personally witnessed why over
300 girls have slept with
guys plus add up all the times.
We all stuck.
We all struck out and why I
think I'm pretty experienced.
And knowing what girls like,
uh, how many girls have,
have you convinced to fuck you?
Um, this is when she cried.
What I didn't know was
she used to be a lesbian.
She quit being a lesbian to be with my
friend and she is sensitive about it.
Yeah. I would think she
would be sensitive about it.
Considering you can't quit
being a lesbian, you either
are one or you aren't one.
Yeah. You know, I kind of blew a couple of
guys, but I quit. Yeah, I didn't like it.
Made me paranoid. Went back
to bed. Giannis um, anyways,
he said I became the I at that
point I became the asshole.
I left the bar thinking two things.
One,
why did half the shit I said come
out with a Boston fucking accent.
And after realizing this, uh, after
realizing the reason why I thought, fuck,
I got to stop listening
to the Goddamn podcast.
Can you believe this fucking guy?
I mean,
there must have been 22 off ramps he
could have taken as that thing developed
into a major fight.
And he chose to stay on the highway.
And then in the end he comes around
and he tries to fucking blame me. Dude.
The reason why you listened to this
podcast is because you just like me now
because I've created
inside of you. All right, the
fuck dude, come on, admit it.
You like doing it. I liked
doing it. I love a women go
in there and they, and they,
and they make some stupid fucking
statement. I love at that point.
I love trashing them because so many
guys just stand there and they just stay.
They just sit there and agree and they
let them say stupid fucking things with
no points behind it because they're,
they're still in that adolescent.
Keep it happy. It'll fuck
me. And it gets annoying.
And you just sit there and you watch
one guy after another getting played for
free fucking drinks, you
know, Carrie and shit forum,
helping them to move and it makes you
fucking annoyed after awhile makes you
annoyed.
But uh,
then then what you do is you get involved
in shit like that and you absolutely
barium. Let me ask you
this dude, how many times,
how many times have you fucking
standing up pointing at her? Huh?
Be Honest. You know, you
even alluded to it yourself.
Were you just sitting there going like,
maybe I said that a little sarcastically.
Of course you did. Of
course you did. You know,
whatever. Do you know you, you fucking
year you got issues with women? Sort of.
Why welcome. Welcome. Fucking join
the Goddamn club. Don't blame me.
Don't fucking blame me.
Go find out where the meeting is and
then tell me where I can go with like a
couple of guys with, with drinking
problems. So if you find out, uh,
okay.
I don't even think what
you did was that bad.
I don't think it justifies
fucking crying either.
I think that whole thing is annoying.
You know what?
I'm going to stop this podcast here
because it's already been over a fucking
hour.
And I know by the end of this,
I'm gonna end up agreeing
with this fucking guy,
which I don't want to do
because this guy is me.
I'd say about 18 months ago, I've actually
made some strides. Haven't I? Cleo?
Right? I got a female dog, didn't
I? I got a bitch laying at my feet.
All right, whatever. There you
go. Another jetlag podcast.
Everybody congratulations
to Philadelphia flyers.
I'm fucking polling for you guys.
It would be great to see you guys win
a championship or even the fucking, uh,
eastern conference finals.
God knows you'd be,
you'd be more better behaved in those
assholes up in Montreal who burned down
their fucking city every time they win.
And then they look down on
us because we're fat fucks.
At least we don't like shit on fire.
You fucking pyromaniac.
Granted we dealt because so,
so many of us are so flammable because
of all that fucking Lard we have inside.
I'm going on with that
man with a fat joke.
I like that people get hurt this
week. All right. That's the podcast.
God bless all the Ia and I will,
uh, I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
okay.
Hmm.